[MUSIC PLAYING]
>> Let me press you on that a little further
since you have an -- a Y
chromosome here.
And I think there might be some men watching
whether here or on YouTube
who will think hey, you know, this isn't my
fight.
I don't have a clitoris.
And what end -- and the same thing, I think,
applies to a lot of other
women's rights issues.
Um, what do you say to them?
Is this their fight or not?
>> Oh, absolutely, it is their fight.
If they care at all about human rights, about
their own freedom, and
their own dignity.
I mean, I think that was my point about the
linkage between the fight
for women's rights and the fight for all human
rights.
I mean, it's not -- we all can very easily
draw the connections between
the status of women in any particular society
and the general status of
human rights in that society.
And that includes the societies in which many
of the people who are
watching this, um, discussion live.
Insofar as -- and it's the experience of my
own, my own life and my own
organization that it was the struggle of women
for their rights that
made us understand our own, our own rights
and the way things are
connected, and the way that -- the approach
that we were taking was a
very narrow and very limited approach.
So I think it's in the vital interest of every
man and we, of course,
don't live in isolation from women.
You know, we have daughters, we have wives,
we have lovers.
We -- you know, it's inconceivable to me that
someone could say this is
not of any interest to me because I'm male
and this happens to women,
any more than I would expect women to say,
I'm not really interested in
what happened to Nelson Mandela because he's
a man and I'm a woman.
I mean what kind of world is that where we
suddenly divide our
feelings?
>> Maybe one more way of thinking about it
is that the Holocaust wasn't
a Jewish issue civil rights weren't a black
issue and FGM isn't just a
women's issue.
>> Right. Exactly.
>> And I think particularly, men play such
a huge part in the
communities that practice this as Anna said
because one of the key
reasons for FGM being in place is it makes
a girl marriageable.
And when, as part of these community conversations,
the men come
together and decide that they will marry an
uncut woman, this is how it
changes within a generation.
And you then move though to the next community
which is the
intra-marrying group.
So men are so vital in this debate and particularly
as religious
leaders as well.
>> And I think when we focus on rights, we
get stuck.
When we focus on economics, which is really
what this all comes down to
is kind of what's a girl worth and is this
about marrying her for her
value -- it changes.
I think because it's girls, people do react
differently than women.
So I think that's going to help bring more
people to the issue.
We've used economic incentives in a number
of cases to get communities
to think differently about early marriage.
And the consequence of the man finally having
a reason to stop and
think about his daughter marrying early or
marrying late, when there's
an economic incentive to do so.
And in the case, in Ethiopia, a girl who stays
in school is eligible
for a sheep or a goat for her family if she
stays in school two more
years.
The fathers have been saying, hmmm, I wasn't
really in the conversation
before.
I had no reason to have the conversation.
I had no reason to think about it.
I had no reason to think about the value my
daughter could bring to my
family if she stayed in school longer.
The economic incentive got him to pay attention.
So I'm for the hybrid solution, which is the
community, the listening,
incentives where we can -- where we can apply
them.
And I know not everybody loves incentives
but I think they work and the
external pressure.
[MUSIC PLAYING]